morteau petite vallée fertile à
l'économie florissante
cet agent immobilier l'a bien compris il
s'est installé ici il y a cinq mois
misant sur la croissance démographique
potentiel de ce territoire
morteau et les alentours compte à peu
près trente mille habitants plus de 8000
son propriétaire en résidence principale
et d'ici 2022 le chiffre devrait être
porté au-delà de dix mille
ce qui sous-entend que le secteur
immobilier de morteau se porte plutôt
bien et accueille de nouvelles
constructions de nouveaux arrivants
florine rognon elle a ouvert sa boutique
de thé café il ya tout juste une semaine
déjà implantée à besançon cette seconde
enseigne est pour elle une belle
opportunité
c'était une petite étude regarder s'il y
avait des concurrents des choses du
potentiel effectivement s'est avéré que
morteau avec le côté un peu frontaliers
on pouvait être intéressant pour ma
gamme de produits ici de taux de chômage
s'élève à 5,5 pour cent c'est bien
inférieur au niveau national les revenus
des travailleurs frontaliers booste le
commerce et je voulais te présenter le
morceau cadeau tu sais lancée par
l'association des commerçants
alors cette année je crois que c'est dit
dix créations quand même sur le
centre-ville uniquement sur le centre
ville de morteau on estime qu'à trente
minutes de morteau ses 95 mille
personnes qui habitent sur notre zone
un salaire moyen qui est important de
l'ordre de 2700 euros ce qui explique
une partie des facteurs clés de succès
du réussite du centre-ville de morteau
et la municipalité encourage ses
installations au centre-ville en
débloquant 5000 euros des d'achat
couverture résultat le taux de vacance
des cellules commerciales et bat 6%
c'est deux fois moins que la moyenne
française